I am not a bad guy I am a good guy
who runs over women with his car
[Laughter]
I'm not a bad guy I'm a good guy
who runs over women with his car
[Laughter]
I am not a bad guy I am a good guy who
runs over women with his car why am I
having such a hard time getting my
message across
[Laughter]
guess what I have flaws what are they
oh I don't know I sing in the shower
sometimes I spend too much time
volunteering
occasionally I'll hit somebody with my
car
so sue me no don't
assuming that's the opposite of the
point that I'm trying to make
we just want to say we're very sorry
screw you guys are dead to me if you say
screw you one more time
whoa okay guys
I didn't a face you like if you say
guys
it makes no sense if you say screw you
one more time for you hey guys just cool
it
you knew you knew that what was that
we just want to say we are very sorry
screw you guys you're dead to me if you
say screw you one more time
hey guys guys
we just want to make it up to you what
can we do
I guess my only wish
would be that nothing's so terrible
would ever happen to anyone else ever
again oh God
okay in a way it's good that it happened
to me because at least I can bear what
kind of cake do you want imbecile
cream
nobody even signed my birthday posture
probably because it doesn't even look
like me it's from last year no
I'm driving
[Laughter]
you're making it work
[Music]
s doctor
what is that
The Longest Time by William Joel that's
your favorite song yeah I want to try
the radio my birthday blows
nobody even saw my birthday poster
apparently my mother
is the only one who cares enough to send
me anything I probably care more than
she does you make it worse
I bet Luke Perry's friends don't treat
him like this
things I guess aren't aren't so bad
after all
okay
[Laughter]
I'm putting together a little
presentation for Michael that's
fantastic yeah I guess it's not so bad
got a few things cooking
um hey we need to get you dressed
Phyllis we gave you one hell of a
wedding shower it was a golden shower
Phyllis we all gave you a gold
we all came in this room for your
wedding and gave you
we all came in here and gave you a
golden shower
well where's my goldish
is this it I mean is this
two bowls of M M's and some balloons you
know what Phyllis I think you need to
step it up I think you need to get the
lead out because if I'm not mistaken we
give you your wedding shower here we all
came into this room and gave you a
golden shower well you know what where's
my golden shower Phyllis over the gums
and through the lips look out stomach
there we go
this was a gift
from Lee Iacocca 20 year old single malt
scotch here is to Mr Iacocca and his
failed experiment the DeLorean
sure
how about some Splenda
all right I'm the I'm the Candy Man
Santa's come early
sure Santa Santa would like to Bear
Santa would like to buy you a pair of
panties little girl
Santa with them
hmm
you don't want anything my treat
some panties or
like a thong or g-string
tea back
get a nice bra
padded bra
see-through push-up lace thigh high
bustier anything it just you know what I
would love
to buy you a fresh set of underwear
Jimbo Last Chance carpool
you know what carpool
carpool yep a little carpool together
working this separately terrible huh
what
car pull together
I'm going to Sebring
carpool
we'll carpool together
I'll meet you there
Last Chance carpool oh no thanks I think
Karen and I will take Michael sure might
be a good idea yeah I went together we
could save some gas but fun long trip
thanks play some games oh
um I spy yeah
Dwight
[Laughter]
yeah
that's right
[Laughter]
which way
I'm here today to do some creative
problem solving about Dunder Mifflin
infinity and field your questions
question Dwight why am I being forced to
come in tomorrow and pretend that a
website made sales that I made this is a
temporary measure to increase the
legitimacy of the site I asked for
assorted Cutlery and I got back spoons
these are worthless
I want to understand what you're saying
but it's difficult for me when you
why do you have to say tone like that
she goes town
I want to understand what you're saying
but it's difficult for me to when you
use that tone
I want to understand what you're saying
but it's difficult for me when you use
that tone
Phyllis
stop it
I'm sorry
that's our Rider
I asked for assorted Cutlery and I got
back spoons these are worthless I want
to understand what you're saying but
it's difficult for me when you use that
tone
Phyllis these are spoons
spoons have rounded tops and are used to
scoop things
what we need are Forks which have prongs
or tiny Spears on top and we need knives
which have blades
do you understand me now
yes
goodie
is here Plantation is running low on
greenbacks
um we ain't got no money to pay the
people who sell us the seeds and dirt
menu I can't do this Michael
basically
[Laughter]
I just got an email from corporate
specifically for accounting to stop all
payments to our vendors what does that
mean well maybe nothing but it could be
a problem with liquidity strange Yankee
accident coming out of your mouth son
this here is Savannah
Phyllis uh
yes
plant plantate this Plantation we were
running long on greenbacks and we're
having problems of paying the people who
give up so slades and the dirt we can't
pay him Michael
I can't
all right